قال الجيش الاسرائيلي في بيان ان منظومه
الصواريخ المضاده للصواريخ بعيده المدى
ارو حيتس اعترضت فوق البحر الاحمر صاروخا
بالستيا اطلق من اليمن كان في طريقه الى
اسرائيل وقال شهود عيان انهم سمعوا دويا
سمعوا دويا انفجار شديد في اجواء البحر
الاحمر القريبه من مدينه ايلات في خليج
العقبه من جانب اخر ذكرت وسائل اعلام
تابعه لانصار الله الحوثيين ان طائرات
امريكيه وبريطانيه استهدفت بسبع غارات
منطقه الجر في محافظه حجه شمال غربي
اليمن معنا من الحديده غربيه اليمن مراسل
الجزيره سمير النمري سمير هل هناك معلومات
عن هذا
الاستهداف نعم عثمان بحسب مصادر في انصار
الله فقد استهدفت القوات الامريكيه
والبريطانيه بسبع غارات مزارع في منطقه
الجر بمحافظه حجه شمال اليمن وهي منطقه
زراعيه حدوديه على مع السعوديه وتطل
مباشره على الساحل البحر الاحمر بحسب هذه
المصادر فان الغارات كانت متفرقه على هذه
المزارع وانها استهدفت اراض ومزارع خاليه
بحسب هذه المصادر لطالما كانت الولايات
المتحده خلال الفتره الماضيه تقول ان
القصف الجوي يستهدف منصات صواريخ وطائرات
مسيره مده للاطلاق بج تجاه البحر الاحمر
وخليج عدن ولكن انصار الله الحوثيون كانوا
يقولون دائما بان هذه الغارات تستهدف
مواقع عسكريه واراض مخلاه من الجنود
والمعدات وانها لا تاثير لها على قواتهم
العسكريه سواء البشريه او المعدات
العسكريه هذا التصعيد ياتي بعد يوم واحد
فقط من اعلان انصار الله استهداف سفينه
بريطانيه في البحر الاحمر وكذلك ايضا
سفينه شحن تجاريه امريكيه كانت تبحر في
خليج عدن وقال الناطق العسكري باسم انصار
الله ان هذه الضربات استهدفت هذه السفن
واصابتها اصابات مباشره رغم النفي
الامريكي والبريطاني لتلك
العمليات زعيم جماعه انصار الله الحوثيون
قال يوم امس ان عمليات قواته ستستمر في
اتجاه البحر الاحمر وخليج عدن وسته القوات
الامريكيه والبريطانيه وان منظومات صواريخ
نوعيه جديده دخلت في الخدمه قادره على
التصدي لهذه السفن واغراقها متحدثا بان
التصعيد الامريكي والبريطاني على اليمن
سيقابل ايضا بتصعيد يمني في البحر الاحمر
والبحر العربي وكذلك خليج عدن متحدثا عن
وساطه صينيه اوعزت من الولايات المتحده حد
للقيام بالتهدئة
حدث خلال الايام الماضيه في قواعد
الاشتباك في البحرين الاحمر والبحر العربي
وخليج عدن وان القوات ستستهدف كل السفن
الامريكيه والبريطانيه وانها لن تكون
قادره على التصدي لصواريخ وكذلك طائراتهم
المسيره شكرا جزيلا لك من الحديده مراسل
الجزيره سمير النبري